i think it's also important to reason
from first principles
rather than by analogy everybody is
feeding yourself
on the hysteria and the negativity
you've got to stay in the light if we
start to do
now and be smart enough
find the right people do the right
things we will win
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more
inside you you've got michael jordan
level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn how
billionaires think and get some success
advice from the top
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one don't reason by analogy with elon
musk
i think it's also important to reason
from first principles
rather than by analogy so the normal way
that we conduct our lives is we we
we reason by analogy um it's we're doing
this because
it's like something else that was done
or it's like what
um other people are doing me too type
ideas
yeah it's like yeah slide iterations
yeah on on a theme um
and and uh and it's
it because it's it's it's kind of
mentally easier to reason
by analogy rather than from first
principles but my
first principles is kind of a physics
way of looking at the world
and what that really means is you kind
of boil things down to
the most fundamental truths and and say
okay what do we
sure is true or sure as possible is true
and then reason up from there that takes
a lot more mental energy
give me an example of that like what's
one thing that you've done that on that
you feels worked for you
sure so um somebody could say um
in fact people do uh that battery packs
are really expensive and that's just the
way they'll always be
because that's the way they've been in
the past you're like well
no that's that's pretty dumb you know
because if if
if you apply that reasoning to anything
new
that then you wouldn't be able to ever
get to that new thing rule number two
have a bigger vision with jeff bezos
i'm taking my amazon lottery winnings
and i'm converting them
into reusable rocket vehicles
so that we can lower the cost
of access to space because right now the
price of admission to do
interesting things in space is just too
high if i look at what
amazon was able to do 20 years ago
we didn't have to build a transportation
network it already existed that heavy
lifting was in place
we didn't have to build a payment system
that heavy lifting had already been done
it was the credit card system
we didn't have to build and put a
computer at every desk that had already
been done too mostly for playing games
by the way
and so on so all the pieces of heavy
lifting were already in place 20 years
ago
and that's why as with a million dollars
i could start this company
today you know and then there are even
better examples on the internet over the
last 20 years you know
facebook started in a dorm room uh i
guarantee you two kids cannot build a
giant space company in their dorm room
it's impossible but i want to create the
heavy lifting infrastructure kind of do
the hard part
so that a future the future generation
two kids in a dorm room will be able to
create a giant space company
rule number three stay in the light with
oprah winfrey
and this is the thing i think i have to
just say please
everybody is feeding yourself on
the hysteria and the negativity you
gotta stay
in the light but one of the reasons why
i was so excited is
about a wrinkle in time because the
message is that the darkness
is spreading so fast these days you must
become a warrior of the light
and the reason that's so meaningful to
me is because that's how i've led my
whole life
and every moment in that film i just
felt like i'm just saying what i've
normally said it's true and and for
these
times the darkness is there to show you
your light
look at what has happened so if you put
the focus on
look at what happened with the darkness
that showed up in parkland
and the darkness that showed up on the
streets of ferguson the darkness
that showed up in many many many many
many many homes
in chicago with shootings and uh
senseless murders
it brings out the best in people it
brings out the best and so that's what
it's there
we live on a planet where there is
darkness
and light also if you want to have
unstoppable confident self-love and
learn from billionaires check out my 254
series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below there are just times when
something is important enough you
believe in it enough that
you you do it in spite of fear in a
world that's changing
so quickly the biggest risk you can take
is not taking any risk those
back-to-back experiences
confirmed what i already knew that that
i was a gas employee and then i better
start my events
rule number four believe in your dreams
with
jack ma 1999 in my apartment 18 founders
the only purpose of time we survived
with 19 people we 18 people gather 50
000 us dollars
we think we can last for about 10 miles
and then raise money
but only four months later no matter how
we tied the budget
we still run off the money so everything
we think about is
to survive but we believe that internet
will change china internet will change
the world
we believe if we don't succeed somebody
will
but if we start to do now
and be smart enough finding right people
do the right things we will win but
later now uh that we're getting bigger
and bigger we
now think it's our responsibility
it's something that it's amazing
somebody put in our heart that we should
do more
because we found we helped created
40 million jobs we helped over millions
of companies
small companies survive why we cannot
help
a hundred million jobs globally why we
cannot help
small business africa middle east
developing countries developing
countries
make them successful by the way the
difference between
artificial intelligence a i
o and uh people is that
machine never have dreams we have dreams
if you don't have dreams you will never
win with machines in the future
rule number five recognize other
people's skills with mark cuban
being treating people equally is not is
not the same
is not recognizing who they truly are
and taking advantage of their skills
you know and i've learned that through
sin i've learned that through all this
and you know like sin and i talk we'll
be a much better organization
i'll be a better exec i'll be a better
investor i'll be a better
um shark um because i recognize that
you know treating people equally is not
the same as treating them
recognizing their skills and their
differences and for this for this
audience
it's critically important you know
and i think there's an opportunity now
and i know hopefully
you know people like me will recognize
that the old white guys now
newly old white guys that are in
positions of power
that there are things that you can do
that i can't do
that there are things you see that i
don't see
there are opportunities that you can
create
that i can't create you know we were
trying to sell
to the black community through the mavs
with multiple white men we were trying
to sell to moms
with multiple white men it's not that
they're not capable
it's not that they're not skilled it's
just everybody brings
something different to the table and as
an entrepreneur
you have to recognize what the
differences are that you bring to the
table and you have to be brutally honest
with yourself
right you can't lie to yourself like we
all lie to ourselves as entrepreneurs
but those differences can be part of
your unique skill set like i talked
about earlier
and now i'm finally starting to
recognize those things
and you know the one thing i know it's
going to make me a load more money
rule number six take on big challenges
with mark zuckerberg
facebook is a for-profit company why
call it dot org
is this a non-profit is this charity
you know if we were primarily focused on
profits
the the most reasonable thing for us to
do
would be to really just focus on the
first billion people who are using our
products i mean the world isn't
set up equally and you know the first
billion people are using facebook
um have way more money than the rest of
the world combined so
from a business perspective it actually
doesn't make a huge amount of sense for
us to put the emphasis in this that we
are right now
the reason why we're doing it is two
things one is mission
right i mean we're here to help connect
the world and we take that really
seriously and
you know you to some degree you can't
really do that if two-thirds of the
world doesn't even have access to the
internet so
you know we just turned 10 as a company
and
we decided that in our next 10 years we
want to take on some really big
challenges in the world like helping
everyone get online and
that's just an important thing for for
us and i think for a lot of other
internet companies and fulfilling this
mission overall
now over the long term i do think it
could be good for for our company as
well
if you look at it in a 10 20 30 year
time horizon
because a lot of these countries and
economies will develop and over time
they will be important
and rule number seven the last one
before a very special bonus clip
is hustle with sarah blakely i feel like
hustle is
the willingness to work really really
hard and then also
your willingness to get the job done
like
kind of navigating and doing what it
takes
and um and so
i yeah i've there's so much about my
journey where i was like i am not going
to let the outcome
or my success be contingent on other
people
as much as i can control it help it
navigate it i'm going to
so um so yeah in the beginning
especially still now i mean obviously
i'm hustling i'm like at the at
this where i am now and i'm running
around the airport asking people to
follow me on instagram you know
i just feel like it's innate in me also
to a degree
um but the uh in the beginning
ex like there's a few examples that come
to mind you mentioned that i paid my i
called my friends and asked them to go
buy spanx and i
wrote everybody checks and sent them a
check
because i needed to drive momentum and i
had no money to advertise so i'm like
this product is going to sit on the
shelf so i needed to get
people to go in and buy it i also when i
went into the stores i realized very
quickly that
my product was in the sleepiest part of
the department store it was back in the
corner and nobody was going there
so then i immediately um
uh went to target and i bought
um envelope dividing dividers that you
put on your home desk
and i ran around neiman marcus and put
them at every register
and i put spanx in them and then i
walked away
and neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and and i did that
because i had to get my product out of
the department and because i did that
women in
shoes started buying spanx and women in
contemporary and
and um those decisions made such a big
difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it
because you know everybody thought
somebody else approved it
it was so successful that the head of
neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it
now i've got a special bonus skip from
john paul de jouria on how to treat
people nicely that i think you're going
to enjoy but before that it's time for
the question of the day i want to know
what is the next big challenge that you
need to commit to taking on
let me know put it down in the comments
below and if you made it this far in a
video you're still here watching i want
to celebrate you because believe nation
we don't just watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're gonna take
action
immediately after watching this video
give me a hashtag believe down in the
comments and tell me where you're from
because i want to celebrate you when i
worked for other
companies some of them not to mention
any names
were so bad they would treat people the
old way
i'm the boss here's what you're gonna do
because i'm the boss right
or there were times for example where
maybe had a dollar for lunch you can't
get a lot for a dollar
so i just knew that that's how i was and
if i had a company
that i had control of my gosh everyone's
going to be treated the way i wanted to
be treated
so the minute we could afford it
everyone had free lunch whether you had
money or not you have free lunch we pay
for it for you
carpool will pay for that so we started
doing things for people
that i wish happened to me maybe that's
part of fate
maybe because a lot of things along the
way weren't so good that as things
started getting good it was so
easy for me to share with our people so
easy to do that
people sometimes don't save money as
soon as we possibly could afford it we
started profit sharing we're at the end
of every year
and we'll take that profit sharing and
put in a retirement fund for you it's
yours
it's yours if you're here so many years
it goes with you no matter where you go
but it's yours that's your money that's
really incredible
and how much do you think that that sort
of golden rule
approach has fed into your ridiculously
low turnover rate which is
literally almost unprecedented i mean
that's crazy
i try and treat people exactly the way
they'd want to be treated
exactly the way i would have wanted to
be treated i'm happy with my people i
realized my people are the company
if my people go my god the company goes
people are your company and they take
care of the customer the customer is
always right no matter what so what do
we do so the customers happier
if somebody's unhappy would try and
discover why
and because you treat people this way
and we love them you walk in our company
it's love
if you go to the front desk here in
century city this girl just has the
biggest smile saying hi welcome to john
paul mitchell system she loves
what she does our big problem is we
don't have turnover we have so many
people out of work for us and the thing
is
you got to wait for somebody to die now
as we grow we'll add one or two on
obviously at a time sure and we're
pretty big now because we're in 96
countries
it's how you take care of people
anywhere in the world you don't blossom
around you including what you're doing
[Music]
if you want even more advice and wisdom
from billionaires check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy
it continue to believe and i'll see you
there reusability is fundamental
um the fully reusable vehicle
will cost 100 times less per flight
you